let me read this post that Michelle
Obama put up because it illustrates some
of the katanji brown Jackson thinking
here she wrote back in college I was one
of the few black students on my campus
and I was proud of getting into such a
respected school I knew I'd worked hard
for it but still I sometimes wondered if
people thought I got there because of
affirmative action it was a shadow that
students like me couldn't shake whether
those doubts came from The Outsider
inside our own minds but the fact is
this I belonged and semester after
semester decade after decade for more
than half a century countless students
like me showed they belong to it wasn't
just the kids of color who benefited
either every student who heard a
perspective they might not have
encountered who had an assumption
challenged who had their minds and their
hearts opened gained a lot as well it
wasn't perfect but there's no doubt that
it helped offer new ladders of
opportunity for those who throughout
history have too often been denied a
chance to show how fast they can climb
of course students on my campus and
countless others across the country were
and continue to be granted special
consideration for admissions some have
parents who graduated from the same
school others have families who can
afford coaches to help them run faster
hit a ball harder others go to high
schools with lavished resources for
tutors and extensive standardized test
prep that helps them score higher on
college entrance exams we don't usually
question if those students belong so
often we just accept that money power
and privilege are perfectly justifiable
forms of affirmative action while kids
growing up like I did are expected to
compete when the ground is anything but
level so today my heart breaks for any
young person out there who's wondering
what their future holds and what kind of
chances will be open to them and while I
know the strength and grit that lies
inside kids who have always had to sweat
a little more to climb the same ladders
I hope and I pray that the rest of us
are willing to sweat a little too today
is a reminder that we've got to do the
work not just to enact policies that
reflect our values of equity and
fairness but to truly make those values
real in all of our schools workplaces
and neighborhoods and apart from the
sheer emetic quality of her prose as
ever I don't know why
um Michelle Obama always feels this
desire to sort of throw herself into
debates like this I mean she's the
former first lady
um uh I don't know are we all waiting to
hear from Laura Bush
no because she had an s.a.t prep person
I'm sure and you know how that means
Melania Trump should weigh in soon on
her thought I mean she's a former first
lady she
um got where she did uh through all
sorts of memes uh but the idea that this
means that she has the sort of Soap Box
about the Supreme Court I find as I say
it's a romantic among other things but
but here's the thing she she admits
something very strange but interesting
at the beginning of that
long-winded statement uh which is she
says that when she was at University she
sometimes wondered whether she had got
there through Merit now as I said in my
column in the New York Post today that's
one of the many secondary effects of
affirmative action is that it suggests
to many people black and not black that
the black students may actually be
lesser than intellectual and cognitive
ability than the others and have been
only able to get there because they've
had an unnatural Boost from the
admissions process so that that as
Michelle Obama shows is something which
actually far from you know giving you
the strength to climb the ladder and all
of those other banal Hallmark cards
insights that Michelle Obama forever
gives people actually
detonate something at the beginning of
your University career which is a maybe
I'm not here on my own merits and here's
one of many other things there's much to
say about this but but um
um see these things through the race
lens now he herself is an exceptionally
privileged person she her she is married
to one of the most privileged people in
the world
their children when applying for college
I think they've already done that but
should they be regarded as right black
applicants to Harvard or wherever or
should their
extraordinarily privileged in fact more
privileged than anyone else in the world
probably apart from the Duke and Duchess
of Montecito should they be regarded as
being
highly privileged and therefore marked
down